في شهر الخير والعطاء وشهر الموائد واصناف
الطعام الكثير من الناس يتجاهلون اهميه
اتباع نظام غذائي جيد في رمضان اما
بالافراط في تناول الطعام او عدم تناول ما
يكفي من العناصر الغذائيه لهذا اليوم
البعض قد يعتقد انه لا ينبغي عليهم ممارسه
اي نشاط بدني وهم صائمون ويتوقفون عن
ممارسه نشاط الرياضي المعتاد تجنبا
للارهاق لكن الحقيقه ان كل ما يحتاجونه هو
روتين جديد لممارسه التمارين الرياضيه في
رمضان مساعده الجسد على التكيف مع الوضع
الجديد واضطراب مستويات الطاقه خلال الصوت
[موسيقى]
دكتوره يعني بدنا نستفيد منها نصائحك
اليوم شو النصائح للحفاظ على غذاء صحي
وجسم صحي في نفس الوقت بدايه الاهم برمضان
اني زي ما حضرتك تفضلتوا في البدايه اني
انا اعمل ارتب اموري ل 30 يوم واحد اني
انا احط خطه ايش انا بدي اجهز لاكلي خلال
30 يوم في رمضان بحيث اني انا اكون متاكد
انه عمليه الطهي وعمليه الطبخ تكون بطريقه
صحيه
وطريقه
ما فيها دهون ما فيها دسومه اللي بيحصل
انه احنا نتغاضى عن السحور ونركز بس بوجبه
الافطار وهذه المعده اللي كانت فاضيه 16
ساعه يتم انه الواحد يهجم على الاكل هجوم
وبالتالي تجهد المعده من الاكل بعد صيام
وبالتالي بيصير تلبس وعشر هضم
والنفخه والكسل والخمول اللي بيشوفوه
الناس الدكتوره في موضوع جدلي يعاد كل
رمضان الصداع في اول ايام رمضان بسبب نقص
الماء او نقص الكافيين في هذه الحاله ماذا
تنصحين خصوصا ان فتره الافطار قبل السحور
الصباحيه فتره قصيره بدايه عند وقت السحور
الناس اللي زيي انا مثلا انا وحده كفر
حولي كتير بحب القهوه عشان اعالج هذا
الموضوع بدايه خففت القهوه اني بدل ما
باخذ ثلاث فراجين صرت اخذ فنجان قبل رمضان
الان احنا في رمضان فالحلقه التالي بعد كل
فنجان قهوه انا بشربه او كل شيء نسكافيه
انا بشربه اخذ كاسه ماء لانه المي يطرد
يطرد الكافيين من الجسم واحد ويرطب الجسم
اثنين اكثروا من السلطه والاشياء اللي
فيها والخطاك التي فيها ماء لانه الان
العلم الحديث يقول كل الماء واشرب الطعام
بمعنى اني انا اكل المي عن طريق السلطه عن
طريق الخس الخيار البطيخ الشمام ليه لانه
بتدخل جوا الجسم والطب الجسم اضافه الى
انه كل انسان بيحتاج لكل كيلو جرام من
وزنه 35 الماء يعني لوزن 60 يحتاج 2 لتر
اما اللي وزنه مئه فبيحتاج ثلاثه لتر ونص
توزع على السلطات والفواكه وتوزع على
الماء ليش لانه جسمك بتحس الصداع الكافيين
بياثر يسبب جفاف للجسم بيطرد المي فانا
عندي جفاف الجفاف هذا بيصير بيصير بسبب
صداع زياده الى ان والتالي انا لما برتب
جسمي بخفف وبمنع هذا الصداع اللي موجود زي
ما حكيت كل الماء واشرب الطعام
[موسيقى]